the Joe Rogan experience my my you a
shooter well dude my ears are covered
for the second time today I'm just gonna
say that and I'm a I'm a asked me like
they and asked me if would you a shooter
that's funny I'm Italian hopper I'm a
tactical shooter bro I'm a tactically so
he ever done we did we went to Terran
tactical today and yeah Brian Cowen
learned the ins and outs learn how to
lean forward that's some Navy SEAL
instruction as well know how to hold a
pistol Whaler yeah how'd you feel I love
it fun right I've been doing it in my
head forever in your head doesn't really
work first
I've rehearsed killing a gang many times
people surround and Shore lean and geeky
when I go like this why don't you shoot
him in the knee and rehabilitate them
that's a good idea because they don't
have knee targets if they had just a
bunch of tiny targets on the ground well
I hit I don't like cuz I'm like what am
i shooting B I was gonna say they're the
size of a toddler yeah that's weird
I'm like alright so I gotta kill the
toddler with one shot kid with a missile
uh yeah I was pretty accurate with that
that's kind of sick but um yeah that's a
good idea I could either waste them or
wing them i wing them and then take them
in and it's teach them the error of
their ways
yeah at the end they'll be loyal to you
I toss them an herbal an herbal remedy
an herbal wrap like Steven Seagal had
and that one movie was in a coma
oh yeah it was kicking his ass a couple
days later I don't care everybody says
that [ __ ] was factual would you remember
that movie very well no no you're way
out of line
well bubs laws the first movie yeah this
was deep but he said his comment what
killing the brother he's got a nurse
yeah he already gotten fat by this song
he had yeah yeah that's where he ran
terribly he always runs terrible yeah
but in the early movies he was skinny
and above the law he was skinny yeah but
then by the time he got to this other
movie where he's in a coma forever like
okay his fingers moving he's waking up
okay look
Oh sexy or wasn't too fat now wasn't too
fat he looks great there but he'd
already you know started to fill in his
hair and so then he was in a coma
forever and then gets out of the coma
remember starts doing all sorts of
Chinese herbs and [ __ ] become about see
he was pretty skinny back then
this is early in the career yeah he
heals himself I would that I would do I
would throw them an herbal wrap and tell
them how to wrap it and then say
training begins tomorrow at dawn I think
you wake them up yeah hey man [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] you and I'd be on
horseback for no reason
really yangsun's why why do you because
there's something very masculine you
have where you're on a horse it's my
entire rack it's my eye I just had this
yeah there are couple things I want to
do before I die one is to toss somebody
an herbal wrap and say training begins
tomorrow or be there tomorrow and I want
to rehabilitate at-risk youth but
they're like 20 and then I want to rear
up on a horse mmm we're up on a horse
but I want to appear out of nowhere rear
up on a horse and rescue a group of
women in the wilderness a group of women
in the Wilden was a in the wilderness
for they got lost with the hikers they
were there plane went down nobody got
hurt but it skidded along the glacier
like they said we can't find them it's
impenetrable it's impenetrable then you
gonna go fetch fetch me fetch the man
Panther the man yeah yeah yeah that's
man you should have do you know about
this guy his name is dick Pro Niki and
he was a guy who lived in Alaska by
himself in a cabin that he built for
decades yeah and he moved out there when
he's 50 years old he got tired of life
and just the way everything was the fast
pace of modern life so this guy decided
this guy amazing videos on YouTube this
guy built his own house out there in
Alaska fashioned it out of logs there's
like a video of him doing the whole
thing filmed everything filmed all of
his interactions with animals birds
would come and land on his hand and he
would really oh yeah yeah he was you he
literally is you
splittin stoic yeah by himself and wrote
you know me stoic and real solitary and
you know real measured with his words of
course and you wanna be and he would sit
and every night he would write and he
would write about his experiences and
the the deep satisfaction then he got
off of living that kind of a life right
doesn't emit some amazing videos pull up
one of the videos so you could watch how
this guy's living his life out there but
you know he would only see people like
once or twice a year or when they would
drop off goods and things that he needed
hmm but this guy was you know he wasn't
a spring chicken he moved out there when
he was in his 50s Wow
yeah when was this I want to say he had
some ways back because I moved back with
his brother I want to say in the early
2000s somewhere around that that looks
like 16 millimeter film that yes yeah oh
dude he lived out there for decades
like I said yeah by himself got I know
you're [ __ ] to be out there by yourself
uh-huh well I think most of it you
learned once he got there and he talked
about it he talked about what the
experience was like about just you know
learning how fatiguing is to hike oh
yeah
learning how fatiguing it is to gather
up your own firewood and he made most of
his own tools are right there he's
making a mallet himself a drill drills a
hole in it with a hand auger and then he
makes his own peg and he only brought in
tools to make tools and the big tools
like that he made all of himself that's
amazing and what did he live on just
deer meat I mean yeah elk meat deer meat
berries
he got some oatmeal and stuff you know
some dry goods that you would he would
get in large but he's coming in touch
base periodically they would come to him
people would fly out to him with goods
but I mean he built all this [ __ ] by
himself he built his whole cabin by
himself and he documented every step of
the way
amazing his name is print at PR o e n n
e ke Nick prenta key alone in the
wilderness is the whole series on
YouTube and he's on the side of a lake
with this this cabin that he built
living off of animals that he hunted and
fire
would and you know whatever food that he
gathered I'm obsessed with this now yeah
I got this Corona thing caught me with
my pants down yeah I want here's what I
want I want a I want a substantial cabin
made of thick logs or stone and then I
want it near a lake or a water source
maybe preferably a well yeah I can
irrigate my own crops you have crops I'm
a chicken I need chickens really only
need a garden you don't need cry I asked
you I need a garden is it just you yes
well it might be me and my several
several lady friends my lady friends
because I'm gonna start my own colony so
I have to breed you understand okay I
need I need a lot of hair and beard I
cuz I want to stay looking young what if
they go up with something that reverses
you an inch now you're talking my
language
how old would seem Claire will actually
have a cabin on the side he'd be right
next to you do an experiment I'm gonna
have his [ __ ] lab and I'm gonna be a
skinny pig yeah you'd be the guy yeah
David come out come on out and I'll just
do Tyson Tyson with all the girls
he'd come well he's not into that he's a
married man leave him alone all right
but he'd like to come out to staying out
in Powell round for a few days he's a
fun guy
he seems like a good guy he's a great
guy yeah he's brilliant and he's
brilliant in the field that's very
important he's what do you mean you're
getting old that's right yeah that's
right you want to be dick brenneke we
had to escape your your wilderness again
again I again too old there are couple
things one more thing I want to do is I
want to split with my shirt off while I
have women watch me through the window
of my log cabin as they're baking me a
pie and I know this is a chauvinistic
fantasy it sounds like don't worry you
selling a real piece of [ __ ] the other
thing I want to do before I die is I
want to have a horse I'm so attached to
it that I can go and and then it just
shows up Oh
so sort of like Brad Pitt's pit bull and
once upon a time in Hollywood correct
I'd kill for one of those that pit bull
was back was [ __ ] great
[Applause]